he's a head football coach at the
Minnesota University of Minnesota Golden
Gophers PJ flag coach welcome to the
show
I appreciate you having us on Ryan
appreciate it a lot you bet so why has
it taken everybody so long to be as
smart as me and have you guys in the top
25 that's probably to decide we've got a
rallied around you you don't know this
but you're a staple in our program in
terms of you picking us and we showed
our team that in training camp and and
we appreciate that but we've kind of
rallied around you as maybe the only
person ever would pick us had some
success but I'm just really proud of our
progress we're making
just on each and every day off the field
and on the field with this football team
you know Chris Brockman here in the in
the studio asked me you know we're the
row the boat mantra came from can you
and you explained to everybody out there
who don't who doesn't know about it what
that means to you your program and to go
for nation yeah I mean it's our it's our
cultural thing right I mean you hear all
these things around college football and
the traditional sayings which you go to
big places for tradition Scott you mom
you know which is here you know fight on
go Irish things like that but row the
boat is really and never give up
attitude us or never give up culture
inside our program February 9 2011 I
lost my second son to a heart condition
and and decided at that point if I ever
become a head football coach we're gonna
find a way to be able to live our life
of serving and giving within our program
and we're going to teach young people
how to be able to be their best
academically athletically socially and
spiritually never give up bring people
inside our program have everybody rowing
in the same direction same speed same
efficiency for the same vision there's
three parts there's an or a boat and a
compass and they all mean certain things
the oar is the energy the boats the
sacrifice and the auras I'm sorry the
boat is the sacrifice the oar is the
energy and the compass is the direction
of your life if you put all those things
together you can do some special things
so it's a never give up mantra inside
our program that's something we rally
behind academically athletically
socially and spiritually and I'm proud
of our players for doing what they do
coach just real
really sorry for your loss but amazing
what you're able to do teaching young
man I compliment you great there those
young kids you have on that football
team right now I look at as a couple
three-headed monsters especially offense
Lee at the running back position and at
the wide receiver position you know led
by Morgan at the quarterback talk to us
about the offensive production and what
those three-headed monsters have meant
to your football team well it's meant
balance you know I mean last year we're
the youngest team in America and you
know still 80 percent of our team is
still only freshmen and sophomores
they're working really hard and when you
have a good ground game in the Big Ten I
think you can have some success I mean
when you look at Wisconsin right now I
mean that's all of them that they are
running the ball they're having a ton of
success and rank really high and have
consistency but in the Big Ten I think
it's all about balance and not only that
I think you have to have as coach Mason
that University of Minnesota said a long
time ago that you need to have a parent
a spare in the big ten to have success
and we feel like we have three guys that
are all equally as talented just do
things differently
oh it's Mohammed Ibraham Rodney Smith
Shannon Brooks we have some young guys
behind them that are very good too we
don't have a senior up front on our
offensive line we're still really young
there but we have we've added some some
size we've got yet guys playing at a
very young age but they're playing
really well congruently playing well
together and then our tight ends are
doing really well and then to help the
run game our pass game we have three
wideouts that I think it hurt anybody in
the country that we play and our
quarterback is just a winner I mean it
just finds ways to win it's a great
leader and when you kind of have that
formula
it all works somehow someway as long as
you keep changing your back yeah talk
about the explosive nature of the last
three games because the first three
against what people would consider
underwhelming opponents but very good
teams in Fresno State on the road then
to come out in Big Ten play and just
kind of explode at Purdue beat an
Illinois my team like crazy and then to
take on a team at home in Nebraska who
everybody thought was going to be much
better than they were but for you guys
to show up in a defensive fashion I
think says a lot about what you have
head of you in particular those final
four games we just want to be today
better today than we were yesterday I
know it's cliche and it's coach speak
but it's true and that's all that we
continue to focus on just one one one
game championship season each thing
every single week our non-conference you
know combined record last year was 32
and eight and we knew it'd be very
difficult there are a lot of new
coordinators a lot of new people that we
didn't know a lot about let's beginning
the season you're learning what type of
team you have the team's learning what
type of team they are just because
you're one thing won last year doesn't
mean you're the same thing this year and
there's a lot of close games at the
beginning of the season for a lot of
things especially group of five to power
five we used to be one of those group of
five teams when I was at Western
Michigan that couldn't wait to play the
power five teams and you know we played
you know an FCS some picked them to win
a national championship at FCS and then
we picked Georgia sub played Georgia
Southern as well which runs a triple
option which takes a lot of your detail
away from your own defense you got
implemented a triple option type defense
and then Fresno State who ended the
season last year in the top 15 so you
know we had a tough non-conference
schedule which I know a lot of people
don't give it credit for but they're
very very talented and beat a lot of
power five teams in the past and then we
opened up a Big Ten play and we're just
getting better in terms of the small
things the details the fundamentals and
looking if you want to know every single
week and our players have stuck to it
yeah they certainly have you're
listening to head coach from the
Minnesota Golden Gophers PJ Fleck I'm
Ryan Leaf filling in for Rich Eisen here
on the Rich Eisen show I want to get
into those final four games and I know
you only talked about today and you got
Rutgers and then Maryland but those
final four games Penn State at home
which i think is huge then on the road
at Iowa home against Northwestern and to
finish the year and possibly what could
be a Big Ten West title matchup talk to
us about those final four games and what
you guys gonna have to do to get better
over the next couple weeks to be ready
for that gauntlet of opponents yeah
you're gonna need my answers I mean I
think every every single week in the Big
Ten for our players we treat it as a
championship season and it doesn't
matter who we play we have to find a way
to be better
we were the week before and that's what
we're gonna continue to focus on Ryan I
mean this team is incredibly focused
they're incredibly mature for how young
they are and they have stayed focused
the entire year on the goals at hand
on the field and off the field I mean
this team has 85 players above a 3.0 GPA
we only have two players below a 2:5 we
don't have anybody on academic probation
or any academic watch lists these guys
were taking their entire life very
serious and they take every day of
preparation serious and we know that we
have six weeks left of the season but
nothing's more important than the game
that we're gonna play this week you know
coach I sit in on the college football
playoff mock committee recently and from
a coaches standpoint and the idea of
expansion and things like that in terms
of the college football playoff what is
your takeaway in terms of that do you
believe that that there's needed there's
more needed than just four teams or do
you think that right now that's the best
we got and it's it really emphasizes you
being an elite and and playing the best
you possibly can throughout the year
yeah I think it leaves it up for
judgment for sure now based on the
people that are in the room I think
change is inevitable I think somehow
someway college football what makes
college football so exciting is the
evolution of our game I think that like
I said change is inevitable at some
point it will probably expand but right
now it's the best as it is because it's
the best formula that we have because
it's the formula we have right now but
as we continue to go and a group of five
conferences that are getting the
attention that they're getting you know
I mean even look at the Mountain West
amount of success they've had against
power five teams this year the AAC you
know there's so many really good power
group of five conferences and you know I
came from the group of five and you know
we had a team that was undefeated and we
never had a chance to even play for a
national championship and it would have
been interesting just to see what we
would have been able to do and some type
of playoff format when I was at Western
Michigan but I still think we're a
little bit a little bit of ways from
that happening but I think it's
inevitable I think the way the college
football's moving whether that's a four
play or whether that's expansion and
college football playoff I think we're
headed that way somehow
some way but as long as it's good for
the student-athletes I support it you
know we're playing at times when you're
talking about 12 games and then you're
talking about a 13th conference
championship game and then you're
talking about playoff games and you're
starting to get into almost an NFL type
schedule and these are still young
people there's still 17 to 22 year old
non professionals as of today and you
know they have classes they've got class
conflicts
they've got all types of things so as
long as it continued to benefit the
student-athlete I'm for it
speaking of that student athlete
California Governor has just passed a
law and into compensating players for
their likenesses and image and I was
wondering what your thought process on
that is if one state takes it into
consideration the NCAA has said right
now that they're not going to abide by
it what's your take away as a head coach
talking about these student-athletes and
what's best for them I'm all for the the
the experience of a student-athlete and
I'm all for the evolution of the college
football experience whatever that looks
like however that happens I know at the
University of Minnesota what we're going
to do is one row is going to provide an
elite experience for our
student-athletes on and off the field
that is the main focus of Mark Coyle our
president gable our athletic director
mark oil and everybody else that is the
main focus of our football team to
provide that elite experience no matter
what and then what we'll do is we'll
lean on the big ten the n-c-double-a and
Bo right along with their guidance of
this whole situation because there's so
many aspects that come into you know
when you're talking about the paper play
that people need to be able to look at
you know you're talking about of
professionalism you're talking about you
know the amateur amateurism you're
talking about title nine you're talking
about all these aspects of it that if
we're going to go down that route and
we're going to go down if there's a lot
of other things that have to happen for
that to happen as well but again I'm all
for the evolution of college football
and the student athlete experience
speaking as the head football coach
University of Minnesota I know that we
will provide the most elite experience
and constant weekend for student
athletes and follow the Big Ten and in
Seattle blaze guidance of how
handle the situation well you've
certainly done that in your first two
and a half years so far continued
success this season I will be of course
watching hoping for the best I'm excited
to see those final four games but I
understand you have the next couple of
weeks coming up so good luck tell your
team that as well thanks for joining us
head coach of the Minnesota Golden
Gophers Vijay Fleck right I appreciate
rowboats caddie Bob go Gophers thanks
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app